make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and uh i have my morning voice on
yes i do how's everybody doing you guys
having a good morning this morning i'd
like to welcome you all to
comics explained on this channel we're
going to be
explaining comic books in a way that
makes them easy for you to understand
everything the light touches is our
kingdom simba
[Laughter]
so what's up guys uh we're covering part
two of uh gwynnam
vs carnage and now that my my sultry
voice has massaged your ears
adequately uh here's the thing about
this and this was so cool i wasn't
really sure if it was gonna be the case
uh going into the second issue but i
have a feeling that this modification to
mary jane watson
is gonna stay right the fact that mary
jane watson from uh the gwynnam universe
has become carnage is gonna be a
mainstay thing and she's gonna become
the arch
nemesis of gwen stacy and it makes the
most sense because usually arch nemesis
in some form of fashion at least if you
follow the old school format when it
came to comics were in some way related
to
or a close friend of the main superhero
character you know as part of that story
so what we end up having here is is mary
jane watson going directly after
gwen stacy right and attacking her on
every front that she possibly can but
one thing to notice about this
is that it's not necessarily some basic
run-of-the-mill villain thing right like
now that i'm a villain i'm going to kill
you and then i'm going to become the new
you know spider-man or something like
that
instead there's a lot of personal
animosity here and that's one of the
reasons why
i say i think this is going to work i
think this is going to work because
one of the things that that really comes
to bear with modern i'm sorry with
mary jane watson i'm so i'm i am not
used to saying mary jane watson
carnage i'm not used to saying that but
one of the things
that that kind of goes on here is that
when you initially have
gwen stacy trying to appeal to the
friendship the two of them shared
because they were band mates for a long
long time
uh carnage rejects it right mary jane
watson rejects it and the reason why is
because while they have been friends
since the sixth grade all she really
recalls are the instances when
spider gwen i've well i don't know we
can kind of call her spiderman all she
really recalls are the instances when
gwenham basically let her down right
gwen stacy spider-gwen gweneth whatever
you want to call her they're all
interchangeable names at this point
but uh but all she really calls the
times when gwynem just let her down
right in the sense that when peter
parker died in her arms and died in the
arms of spider-gwen
and then basically like she just left
everybody right she just she just took
off and left everybody right allowed her
friends to be kidnapped by a madman now
the reality of this situation and this
is this is kind of the issue that goes
on here
is what you have are two different
recollections of a particular series of
events
the the problem with this is that mary
jane watson doesn't really seem to
recall or is refusing to recall
things as they truly happen but just to
say we as the reader
know what went on right that gwen
stacy's spider-gwen right she's a
superhero
and she kind of has this torn allegiance
between saving the city of new york
doing what she can to fight off
villains like matt murdock and then at
the same time to also like maintain her
friendships and her allegiances and this
is one of those things that really made
her character popular for those of you
guys who
never really read spider-gwen it's one
of the things that made her character
the most popular because when you looked
at spider-man the struggle of spider-man
did come
somewhat in the early days but he also
revealed his identity to the people who
were important to him
somewhat relatively fast it wasn't done
right off the bat but there was a kind
of balancing act that was struck there
the way that stanley and steve ditko and
even later writers handled that
balancing act was that it was always on
a knife's edge but somehow peter was
always able to sort of maintain this
balance to a degree he did run into a
few hiccups and a few bumps every now
and then but one of the big things that
went on with spider-gwen
is that she was never really able to
maintain that balance she was never
really able to keep that kind of
work-life balance intact right like it
was just these times where she would
have to go be spider-gwen in the most
inconvenient circumstances
this was especially prominent when it
came to the mary janes right the band
that she was in that was led by mary
jane watson and that's the thing that
kind of happens here we are given a few
little easter eggs or not really easter
eggs but a few little revelations
for example that the little tiny spiders
that normally make up spider-gwen suit
are now
part of mary jane watson's suit she can
re-materialize things and change things
so like
she turns a uh she turns a guitar into
like a giant axe
right that kind of a thing and we also
end up learning that the spiders that
make up the the carnage suit cannot be
controlled by by gwen stacy right so
that's one of those other instances
where i think that mary jane being
carnage is going to be something here to
stay right but regardless of the
situation
what ends up happening here is that mary
jane ends up getting the upper hand on
gwen stacy and when she does
she effectively sends her to meet noel
and when she travels to meet null this
is kind of an interesting encounter
because she's not from this universe and
this is one of those things where it
seems a little wonky the way that null
is being done because he's kind of being
shown inconsistently
in marvel comics right he's a person who
existed before the current universe took
form but then you read back and it's
also he existed before
anything took form he was just kind of
existing in this giant void of empty
space and then somewhere along the line
the celestials popped up they started
creating life and pissed him off they
got into a fight and then
nola was banished from the universe and
he just kind of you know eventually
returned and then he was locked inside
the symbiote planet
done right it's just it's a pretty
simple and straightforward idea behind
his character but he's kind of given to
us as both a multiversal and a universal
character now it could just be
that he just hasn't stumbled across gwen
stacy's universe yet that he's conquered
other universes there are other places
under his control something along those
lines we're not really given a whole lot
of information
in so far as like the grand scheme and
everything he'd done
in the time that he was actually
operating out in existence and so on but
regardless the idea here
is that when he when he really appears
before gwen stacy
that he finds her curious right he's
like i don't know
i don't know who you are right like
you're not from this place so why am i
not able to control you now the reality
is
her suit is a synthetic suit right it's
not an actual symbiote suit and that
really seems to be the reason why
noel cannot actually pick up on her
because by all standards of measurement
she
looks like somebody possessed by a
symbiote but the symbiote that she has
is not one that null created and so
that's why he's a little like
this is a little strange so then it
turns into playing a few mind games and
when she kind of asks the question like
you know how is it that mary jane
got so twisted and so screwed up you
know what did you do to her the response
of noel is i didn't do anything
i just brought out how she felt right i
just gave her like this kind of release
for all this emotional
anger that she had pinned up and he
starts showing her these images from her
universe
that even when you even before gwen
stacy ever became
spider gwen that you ended up having of
course her and mary jane kind of working
on the idea of a band
and it was really more of when stacey
kind of getting lost in the idea and
almost kind of blowing off mary jane you
know where mary jane's just like we're
gonna be the best man around we're gonna
be famous you know where we can even
play for prom and just sort of you know
she's being tuned out by gwen stacy when
stacy just caught up in the idea
and so it's one of those things where it
was like even when gwen stacy was there
she wasn't really there that became even
more prominent when she became spider
gwen that not only was she not there
mentally she wasn't there physically
right and the times were like they
needed her because she was the drummer
and she was the person that was gonna
you know make sure the band
stayed on beat and all that kind of good
stuff right the role of the drummer in a
band that she was out fighting villains
like the lizard and things along those
lines and it is a little unfair to kind
of approach that situation and say you
need to be here for the band but the
reality is that
at that time mary jane watson didn't
know that spider gwen was gwen stacy
right she didn't know who she was and so
she didn't know
that she was leading this kind of dual
life right she didn't really understand
that's what was going on and that's one
of the things that that null kind of
hits on that he sort of pulled out of of
mary jane by having her become carnage
or at least seeing her become carnage is
her becoming this kind of twisted up
version of herself
is because she's just filled with so
much anger and and so much rage but if
anything
it's more of a feeling of betrayal
that's the feeling that that mary jane
watson feels that she feels betrayed by
her best friend that in the time when
they were supposed to work together for
the band and the time that they were
supposed to hang out when they were
working on this great huge project they
had the potential to be
you know super special because of the
band they were working on and things
like that but it was always gwen stacy
seemingly overshadowing
mary jane watson in more ways than one
right always seeming to draw the
attention to herself
you know like whenever she would she'd
face somebody and then she'd come back
and she'd be late
it was one of those things it was just
like i wanted to make sure you guys know
i could just come and go as i please and
you operate on my time like that kind of
attitude right that a lot of people seem
to get carried away with when they get
famous
and so the result of that is there's a
lot of anger here that's really where it
comes from and that's what makes the
idea of the spider-gwen story so cool
right the gwynemon spider-gwen whatever
that's what makes the story so
interesting is
there's so much interpersonal
involvement between the characters that
when you see the villains it's not like
it's one of these things of
you know well i just got these powers
through some weird fluke and i've always
been down on my luck so i'm just going
to go rob banks it's nothing that basic
you know that the idea of the connection
between carnage and gwynem is a close
one it's not some it's not like
spider-man
and cletus cassidy where cletus
cassidy's just a crazy guy who just
wants to inflict you know as much pain
and death
and carnage on people that he possibly
can that mary jane watson as carnage
legitimately has
so much pent-up hatred and anger towards
towards gwen stacy that has driven her
to the point that once she's lost her
mind
two she's allowed herself to be
possessed by a multiversal symbiote god
and three she's trying to kill her best
friend
i don't know about you guys but that
sounds like a lot of anger to me
it's it's the interpersonal stories that
take place the the connection between
the characters that take place and the
spider-gwen stories that make them so
good
right that's what makes her character so
cool that and like the costume right the
outfit that she has which is which is
really amazing now
there is a moment where she does manage
to connect with mary jane
on a on on a personal level right
there's this really really brief moment
here when she tells her
that the the carnage suit is an
extension of of the
the suit that gwynnam wears and because
it's synthetic the suit is
constantly consuming right constantly
feeding and that she doesn't really have
the ability to keep the suit at bay
the same way when stacy does and the
suit will consume her it will eat her it
will it'll kill her but it'll destroy
her physical body
and while there is this brief moment
where where mary jane's like what you
know like no no no like
i don't want to die like the the carnage
suit takes right back over again and so
it's one of these things
where i wouldn't go as far as to say
that it looks like you've got a kind of
like rogue carol danvers such a
situation going on where like one
consciousness is trying to dominate the
other i don't really think it's anything
like that but it is one of these things
where for a brief moment she was able to
talk her down and then her anger took
back over again and it's like
no you're lying you're just trying to
take away my ability to be special right
that kind of a thing and so of course
this basically leads to the fight
essentially ending and then you have or
at least ending temporarily you have
uh mary jane who takes off to kind of
take her place next to null i kind of
makes this argument that null is going
to make me
you know the most special person there
ever was right and i've got i've got
i've got houses to rock and i've got
people to kill
all kinds of crazy stuff but i'm sure
you know of course we have one issue
left right this is only a three issue
series um i don't really know exactly
how it's going to wrap up but again my
money is on the idea that mary jane
watson is going to somehow be teleported
back to
to the earth 65 universe and she's going
to end up becoming carnage she's going
to end up becoming the main villain
of spider-gwen and it makes perfect
sense right given the evolution of the
relationship between the two the
evolution of their characters
it makes perfect sense that's what would
happen so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you